the Trump administration is readying
itself to mount a powerful defense in
the Senate so what is the best argument
for Trump against this impeachment sham
our next guest spent the weekend golfing
with President Trump and joins us
exclusively trey Gowdy is a former South
Carolina congressman a Fox News
contributor a former federal prosecutor
and somebody I was able to serve with in
the previous Congress congressman thanks
for being here now I got a picture of
you golfing with the president now check
out this form that is quite the swing
great backswing and in the background
you can actually see the president
looking off into the trees and bushes to
figure out where that ball actually went
Trey well it's a 50% chance to go on
left and a 50% chance of going right the
only place you need not look is right
down the middle of the fairway when I'm
hitting the driver
you're pretty good golfer I getting
serious here are you going to represent
President Trump coming into 2020 no the
president's got great lawyers JC and
more importantly than having great
lawyers he's got great facts I think for
several months we've been talking about
the process and how fundamentally flawed
it's been
I mean imagine being investigated by
somebody like Adam Schiff that's it
that's the process but Jason I focus on
the substance the single best piece of
evidence for the president is the
transcript itself you know because
you're familiar with the transcript this
was the second phone call the president
Trump and President azulon ski hat if
President Trump were really obsessed
with conditioning aid on investigations
he would have brought that up in the
first phone call right I mean if you're
really obsessed with it you're gonna
bring it up every chance you get go pull
the transcript from the first phone call
not a single word look at the remainder
of that transcript what did the
president say he said I want you to do
us a favor and then for those wondering
who Isis us is he answered it he said I
want you our country has been through a
lot so the US is linked to our country
who brought up rudy giuliani's name was
that Donald Trump or was that president
szalinski it was president Solinsky
that's who introduced Rudy Giuliani into
the conversation the only thing
President Trump did is he inserted bill
Barr and if it
teachable offense to ask the Attorney
General the top law enforcement official
for the country to look in to potential
impropriety if that's an impeachable
offense no well I gotta have presidents
serving very long I've got a question
about Joe Biden and the compliance with
the subpoena I mean to hear Joe Biden
say it depending on which hour he asked
him he's pretty much covered every
number on the bingo card I can't exactly
tell what his latest thinking is but
would a Joe Biden have to comply with
the Cena a a subpoena if it was it was
proffered yeah if you don't like Joe
Biden's answer just wait about an hour
and he'll give you the exact opposite I
found that dumbfounding he
single-handedly gutted one of the two
articles of impeachment when he said by
the way y'all are trying to remove a
president from office for doing what I
just promised to do while these
Democrats are supporting Biden that's
the exact same conduct he's not going to
comply with the subpoena which is what
one of the two articles impeachment
against Trump is does he have to comply
he can go to court he can move to quash
it and he can come and evoke some
privilege if he has one that he's
entitled to but that's exactly president
Trump's position if you want Mick and
Bolton to testify then take them to
court and have the third branch order
them to appear but but Schiff in the
House Democrats didn't want to do that
no it is rich to actually hear
Senator Schumer make the claim that they
need a fair trial they need all the
documents they need witnesses when in
the house they didn't even give him a
chance to have a minority witness day
it's rich for any Democrat but you have
Democrats who have already said the
evidence is overwhelming despite the
fact that not a single piece of evidence
has been introduced and from them they
said the the facts are undisputed the
fact despite the fact that the trial has
not begun yet you have what a half dozen
members of the jury that that are
running for the job or the person they
are supposed to be sitting and
dispassionate judgment of you would
never have that in any real fair
judicial proceeding so the notion that
this is somehow like a courtroom where
you have 12 people who have not made up
their mind to me
one out of 100 good luck finding twelve
out of a hundred who have not made up
their minds I can think of maybe six
maybe six that a full-blown trial with
witnesses and exhibits might move one
way or the other but the other 94
they're gonna vote the same way whether
the trials today or whether it's a year
from now so let's go to Pelosi in this
delay I mean it's if you actually go
back and read the articles that were
passed in the house the Democrats wrote
them they passed them all by themselves
and it also says that those articles
will be exhibited to the United States
Senate but Nancy Pelosi as the speaker
has not transferred them over a does it
matter if she transfers them over and
then B why would you delay it the way
she is
I don't know JC I mean if he's an
existential threat to the Republic I
mean if we really are faced with this
the this once in in a 200 year abuse of
power why in the world you would be
sitting on the indictment and not
sending it over for it to be tried if
you Republican Speaker of the House I
promise he should be asked a lot more
about it but I haven't ever heard her
ask much and the last week I've always
thought this is about the Senate it's
not about keeping the house because I
think they're going to do that this is
about putting a handful of Republican
senators in tight spots in November Cory
Gardner and Tom Tillis and and Susan
Collins and martha mcsalley put them in
tight spots make them cast difficult
votes because even when Trump is
re-elected and I think you will be in
the fall of 2020 if he doesn't have the
Senate he's gonna be essentially
neutered as a president in terms of
getting his getting his cabinet so
that's always what I thought this was
about and and her actions tend to
confirm that and if he she does
eventually transfer them over that could
happen tomorrow it could happen
I don't know never but if she were to
actually do that is it legitimate to
call up say a hunter Biden or the
whistleblower or this do you have to
deal with those in a very different way
in a Senate trial yeah I mean Jason what
I would tell the Republic is it
don't call any witnesses I mean it's
it's the House Democrats job to a built
the case and they could have gone to
court and they could have come compelled
Nick to testify and Bolton they could
have honored Devon and and and and John
Radcliffe and and Doug Collins request
that hunter Biden testify and do any of
that so the investigation is over this
is the trial presented on the paper
presented on the depositions make your
opening and closing statements and then
vote me if the trial were today the
president would win and I don't think
he'd lose a single Republican senator
and he might pick up one Democrat so if
you have the jury and you know how
they're going to know how they're gonna
rule go ahead and get it over with and
then the president can say whatever he
wants to after the trial is over I don't
believe in calling witnesses when I
don't know what they're going to say I
mean this is not a drama this is not
something where we need a really
spellbinding exciting ending I like no
drama when it comes to trials and he's
gonna win if the votes today list so
let's go ahead and get the vote over
with all right I got to ask you real
quickly in her parting question here
about Peter struck he came out made
another comment today about his First
Amendment rights to tweet or say or text
whatever he wants to say as a federal
employee
what say you yeah I mean if he were
really confident is the First Amendment
rights I don't know why he would have
offered to take a demotion often to take
a cut and pay if he held on to his job
Jason you and I have a lot of respect
for law enforcement I really can't think
of anyone who's done more damage to the
FBI's brand in the last 18 months than
Peter struck so I'll just tell your
viewers for everyone Peter struck there
are a hundred fantastic FBI agents you
just don't know their names
don't judge that that that that entity
that agency by the Peter structure of
the world
he's a one-off I'm glad he's out he
never should have been investigating
president Trump I'm glad he's out of the
FBI and I hope he loses the hell out of
his lawsuit oh thanks congressman Gowdy
I really do appreciate it happy new year
happy New Year to you and Julie C thank
you